welcome to metaphysical milkshake i am
your host reza aslan and i am the better
host rayne wilson
you are the better host and you know
you're a better friend too rain than i
am i would have to say are you not a
good friend to people
i am a good friend
to the like
three
people that i would legitimately call my
friend i i don't have a lot of friends i
went to your 50th birthday party sorry
to date you
and uh you had like 37 your wife had a
surprise dinner and like 37 people were
there i don't think my wife could pull
together 37 people for a surprise dinner
that was pretty good well you know
that's a good point and in fact the
weekend before that she had gotten like
all my high school friends together too
but like it was beautiful seeing them
and i and i would definitely you know
call all of them my friends but
how how many of them would i call
like a close friend how many of them
would i call a best friend that's
that's a tougher question
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so you're an immigrant kid growing up in
the united states was it difficult to
make friends with did you keep friends
seems like you you became social pretty
quick you were in church groups you had
a rock band do you have a lot of good
friends from your high school days
i do but i think maybe my definition of
best friend is a little bit different
than other people's like i basically
have one best friend you know and and
the way that i would think about a best
friend is that somebody
that i am as close to now
that as i was you know when we first met
like i met that best friend
uh when i was 16 and he was 17 in high
school and
you know that for
coming up on you know whatever almost
35 years or something like that yeah
here we are
you know still as close as ever
um and then i have another sort of i
would say like a secondary best friend
that i met at grad school
but that's kind of about it see this is
the thing rain i don't know if you're
like me but like
i don't have time you guys are making
new friends yeah i have [ __ ] to do i
have literally [ __ ] to clean up you have
you have literal [ __ ] and you've got
like 18 kind of shows you're developing
or shooting or hosting at at any given
time you're a workaholic you're a
parent-a-holic who's got time for
friendships who has time by the way this
isn't just me it's uh it's interesting
because i grew up i had this best best
friend named john
um starting from like fourth or fifth
grade through high school and even at a
college we both went to nyu together he
went into film school i was in the
acting school and many many years
thereafter in our 20s and then he got
married started having a couple kids
moved out to long island i moved to los
angeles and it just became too hard you
know it just
um
we fell out of touch you know it's uh
uh
unreturned phone calls and just not
hearing and
you know men can often be super bad at
communicating and like sharing and
whatnot and and it's too bad because we
were really really uh close and your
interests start to
shift a little bit you know
uh i mean you're you went all hollywood
so you probably don't even have time
totally sold out you know like well i
would i got i'm hanging out with tom
cruise and i'm on a plane with leo
dicaprio so i i can't have friends
and then like with in my case like my
wife became my best friend and so it
happens to a lot of guys i threw all of
my time and effort into hers look the
point is is that this isn't just
an issue that you and i are dealing with
there was a poll that came out in 2021
49
of all americans said that they have
three
or fewer
friends
and i would put that i would put that if
if it's close friends close yeah yeah
three or fewer close friends i would
definitely put myself
in that cabinet in that category and
fewer americans today have a best friend
than in 1990 75 in 1990 59
now so we're losing best friends as well
we've talked before we've had episodes
about the epidemic of loneliness but
friendship the building the sustaining
of friendships the connection that
friendships give us the difficulty in
initiating and maintaining friendships
seems to be on the decline along with
everything else in this godforsaken
world and there are some serious health
consequences to that as well not just
mental health consequences
loneliness obviously but uh even
physical health like your actual
uh you know health is improved by having
uh you know a lot of friends but here's
the problem
all the surveys about friendship pretty
much all the same say the same thing
that basically you know the average age
the average age that you meet your best
friend is 21 years old and by the time
you hit your 30s forget about it like
the 30s that's the decade where
friendship goes to die now now we're
usually starting to have kids in our 30s
that's right these days people used to
have them in their 20s but now more than
30s even 40s so that brings us uh to i
think a very important question it's a
metaphysical question but it's a it's a
health question it's a mental health
question should we have kids sure
that's not what i was gonna say but i
see how you where are you headed out
there are you headed with this
how do grown-ups make friends yeah
i mean i'm asking for a friend how do
grown-ups make friends i i don't know
um i'm not very good at it but you know
what i know a couple of gals that might
have some insights
they wrote a book about it they met
apparently on the the set of a tv show
and
they've become super good
super good friends there was a show
called friends
so please
welcome to the show courtney cox
no close close instead it's jenna fisher
and angela kinsey from this little known
show called the office which apparently
i guess was on tv and people people
loved it you know
jenna she played pam on the show you
know
angela because she played angela on the
show by the way not a lot of creativity
in naming the character it shows you how
lame the show is i couldn't even name
the characters show but they these two
gals they met on the set and they
instantly became best friends and they
have now
documented that friendship in an awesome
new book called the office bffs tales of
the office from two best friends who
were there notably uh you are quite
absent from this book but we'll we'll
discuss that a little bit later a couple
of things to know about jenna and angela
uh they are both uh well-regarded
actresses obviously um they also have a
fantastic podcast uh called the office
ladies podcast which i guess they just
talk about office episodes and
you know tens of thousands of people
listen i mean tens of thousands like
tens of millions of people listen i i i
honestly feel like we may have screwed
up in our podcast idea rain yeah you
know this we're not really taking
advantage of your celebrity
uh in this podcast we should wait every
episode we should watch an episode of
cheers and comment on
this is exactly
but
they've got some great advice for us
some fantastic advice about how to how
to make uh friends
and uh apparently you know you even know
them kind of they are
lovely powerful brilliant women let's
get this show started i'm gonna bring
angela actually into the studio with me
today reza she's here apparently just
finished parking and uh we'll bring
jenna on the zoom and we'll get this
thing going
omg
angela
angela's here later later let it breathe
[Music]
strangely that's how he begins all our
podcasts
and janna's here hi jenna
hi oh my god wait where's my song
where's my song i get nothing i just get
here's jenna
angela got a whole
loop
what do i get
i can sing for you if you want jenna i
can sing a song grezza will you sing me
a song please jenna needs a theme song
hello
jenna i said hello
jenna it's so nice to have you on the
pod today
wait jenna gets hello dolly rendition
and i get like
nervous
backwards
backwards
none of this is gonna make the cut oh
please this is all gold this is all in
folks ladies and gentlemen uh the launch
of this most incredible a historical
epic of the office bffs
uh jenna fisher and anza kinsley to
whatever your name
office from two best friends who were
there based on their podcast incredible
filled with so many there are so many
photos of me in here there are more
photos of me in here than my and then i
ever had as a child growing up in my
family photo albums rain i took a lot of
pictures of you
i love this book i it was it was such a
wonderful read
but it was also such a surprise to me
because like i've known rain for what
like a decade
i had no idea that he was on this show i
love this show
yeah it's good right you were in the
office yeah yeah he played dwight it was
a recurring character i had a few arcs
right yeah
but um but we were so thrilled to to
bring you i get to be in the same room
with you i know angela quincy
and uh
and we get to uh
talk about
friendship so you know we do a podcast
on life's big questions but and there's
a central one here which is about the
friendship and nature of friendship but
take us back to the very very beginning
because in reading this book i didn't
really realize it like it started
in the pilot with your little little
blonde popinjay head popping up over the
divider
take us back
17 years ago i'm very shy in new
situations and i was very nervous the
office pilot was
like one of my first big jobs it was my
first lead role and
so i was keeping to myself and i was
over there at reception i didn't have a
desk mate everybody else had a desk mate
but angela was closest to me she was
right over that little partition and she
would just pop her little head up and
just start talking to me she was so
friendly and outgoing the total opposite
of her character she was like hi jenna
i'm angela
well i heard her sneeze and if i mean
her sneeze it doesn't it sounds like a
little like woodland creature she's like
and i had tissue on my desk and i
thought this poor girl is having an
episode of like sneezing allergy thing
so i poked my head over and i was like
would you like a kleenex do you guys
remember when like for one of our wrap
parties the editors did a whole reel of
just me sneezing and ruining takes
because i sneezed so often yes i will
never forget that sound i will never
right it stays with you
that sound i mean it was about 18 times
a week yeah it sounds like that because
i'm suppressing it because i was
trying not to ruin takes but every once
in a while a little sound would still
come out a little sound it's like
yeah
yeah
but then sometimes your body just
couldn't take it anymore and it was like
i am going to sneeze
public goods is the one-stop shop for
sustainable high-quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
personal care and household products to
coffee toilet paper shampoo pet food and
more public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer so rather than buying
from a bunch of single product brands
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place
with one beautiful streamlined aesthetic
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
innovative products they ethically
source and obsessively develop each of
their products to be free of unhealthy
ingredients and harmful additives still
common on drug and grocery store shelves
they are committed to making their
products healthy and safe for humans
animals and the environment they use a
membership model to keep costs slow and
pass on even more savings to their
customers best of all you can make your
first purchase with no obligation join
hundreds of thousands of others who have
switched to their new everything store
so we have worked out an awesome deal
received 15
off of your first public goods order
with no minimum purchase that's right
they're so confident that you're gonna
love their products and you're gonna
come back again and again and again
they're giving you 15
to spend on your first purchase look you
got nothing to lose all you got to do is
go to publicgoods.com
milkshake or you can use the code
milkshake at checkout that is p u b l i
c g o o d s public publicgoods.com
forward slash milkshake and you receive
15 bucks off your first order
[Music]
what made you both know and jenna
especially for you because angela would
be friends with anything that walks and
talks but for you i like people you guys
i really do i get really excited to meet
new people i mean i met travis and
olivia today already
i know anyway
i didn't even know who they were i
didn't have forgotten their names i've
done
37 episodes with them
but how did you how did you make that
transition jenna i'm like i'm gonna be
friends with this girl this is gonna go
beyond just visiting on the set we're
gonna hang out we're gonna talk on the
phone we're going to chitty chat
till 3 a.m talk about boys well it
didn't happen on the pilot it did not
happen on the pilot we did not even
exchange phone numbers after the pilot
and there was no social media so it
wasn't like i could follow her or like
dm her none of us rain i didn't get your
phone number after the pilot we just
sort of all yeah we just all said
goodbye yeah yeah so luckily our show
got picked up and it was actually during
the basketball episode
angela and i were placed on the bench
together and we were in the background
of all of those basketball scenes all of
those basketball rehearsals that you
guys were doing all those setups we just
sat on that bench and
in those couple of days
we told one another our life stories
we we started out with just like where
are you from but we ended on like your
hopes and dreams and what's not working
in your life and what do you wish for
yourself for the future like i mean we
went
all the way
sitting on that bench telling each other
everything and that is when
i can point to saying okay this person's
going to be my friend but also i think
this person is my best friend i think
this is like my
this is my friend's soul mate we also
share a real level of dorkiness that
makes me happy i mean at the end of that
warehouse scene we were walking through
the parking lot it was late at night and
we locked arms we didn't discuss this we
just locked arms and we looked at each
other and immediately started doing
laverne and shirley
and
i'm
anyway and we just started laughing and
i just thought well this is someone that
feels like home to me well see this is
really fascinating because um one of the
things that that we had talked about was
that i'm sorry why are you here
yeah rain i'm sorry i'm the i'm the
podcast host here
we're reminiscing about the office yeah
you guys just talk about old times and i
will actually do what we are here to do
which is ask questions thank you
um
you know we were talking earlier about
the fact that
uh age 25 apparently like age 25 is when
people have the maximum amount of
friends and then it's all downhill from
there and and it's uh i i think most
people
would agree with this that it's in your
30s that it becomes
very unlikely that you make a new friend
um especially a best friend like that
doesn't really happen
later in life so i'm curious like
was it just the fact that you guys were
thrown together for so many hours where
you had very little choice but to just
become close to each other that allowed
you to get over that that hump that so
many people have about you know getting
having new friends later in life what do
you think angela i mean it's true we met
in our 30s and we weren't looking for a
best friend you know like we i wasn't
yeah but i also i had my least number of
friends in my mid-20s i was new to los
angeles i hadn't really done a good job
of keeping in touch with any of my
college friends that i left behind
i had a hard time making new friends in
los angeles in the city that i didn't
know
i mean
that was like my loneliest stretch when
it came to friendship so maybe one of
the things that opened me up to having
a friend in angelo was that i was
you know i was a little lacking in the
whole friendship department
at that point in my life i was
definitely craving that friendship
connection for me in my 20s i mean i was
having a parties where i made shirts and
um you know themes and
i i love a party guys i was a party
planner in my heart in my heart of
hearts um and so i think i was in a huge
i don't understand making shirts you're
like in a sweatshop no like at my party
you would walk in and your party favor
would be a shirt i made a t-shirt and
i'd order like 200 of them you'd make
shirts for everyone who's everybody yes
come on come to my party get your
t-shirt yeah or maybe a koozie
right i don't know what that is acousy
is the thing you put your beer in and
it's got your lunch you want your beer
cold even i know that yeah all right
cheers to your 25th birthday party
picture of angela going
so you're like a professional friend
then basically i was i just was very
social
and i think for me with jenna
i
i don't know i just
it was so comforting she felt like
someone who was going to be there no
matter what when the t-shirts ran out
rain yeah when there weren't any more
koozies yeah yeah um
she just felt just tried and true and
she is like that she's incredibly loyal
and she's there for you she takes you
wherever you're at and i really
appreciated that and i picked up on it
pretty quickly and i thought well this
person is going to love me no matter
what and
it's been the greatest gift like having
this friendship i've gotten a lot of
t-shirts out of it too i do want to say
angela has made me several t-shirts she
made me a t-shirt with a piece of bread
on it
she made me um i made you a a wine label
with our picture on it
i made you a scrapbook for your birthday
with all these different pictures of us
being silly
yes it's true you guys that's so that's
so that's so perfect so what makes a
good friendship i mean
this obviously this one came
easily to you some friendships don't
come
quite as easily maybe require a little
bit of
i won't say work it's not quite the
right word but um
focus and attention but i do think good
friendships are you work at you know
it's like any other relationship that's
worth anything you check in what does
that look like what does working at a
friendship look like jenna and i talk
every single day okay that's crazy every
single day now we don't always we're not
always able to be on the phone with one
another because of kids and life and
work and but we leave each other a voice
memo every day we've done it for
how what jenna 18 years now
yeah at least 10 years
like just checking in and you can listen
to it whenever like sometimes we put a
little message like you gotta listen to
this one before friday okay and then the
other ones would be like listen whenever
you're like doing chores or you're
traveling and bored and
we just share i always know what jenna's
up to there was a time when she was
filming in london and i had gotten a job
in israel and we were trading these
voice memos at different times of the
day and night and i i it was so
comforting every time i got to hear her
voice it was like this safe place where
everything felt familiar well it seems
like you guys are able to share like
recipes and funny stories about cats but
you're also really able to share like
yeah when you're heartbroken and feeling
down and
at your most vulnerable is that is that
true jenna
that's definitely true
you know on the subject of friendship i
do think that there are different
friends for different seasons of your
life
and i think that time in your 20s that
angela was talking about that's like
for a lot of people that's a really like
that is your social season
you know that's when you have room for
lots of
acquaintances and good times and a lot
of socializing outside the home
but then like maybe when
your career is taking off or
you have children
like that's a different season of your
life and sometimes those friends don't
always travel with you and
by the way i think that's okay you know
what i feel lucky about with angela is
that our friendship has traveled through
these seasons although our biggest bump
in our friendship was when angela became
a mother before i did when she was a
parent and i wasn't a parent because i
was still a little bit in that uh sexy
social season of my life and um i called
it jenna's sexy life like i had a
newborn and jenna would text me at nine
o'clock want to grab dinner and i'm like
nine o'clock i'm in bed
are you crazy or i remember one time
rain you said to me i was like you had a
later call time and i was like um how
was your morning and you're like oh man
i took the best nap and i said in the
morning because i hadn't had kids yet
and you're like yeah i had a morning nap
you'd been up you know with your son
and and i you kind of remember little
conversations like that as soon as you
become a parent and jenna was very much
in her sexy life we talk about it in the
book but
we we were very disconnected and we had
to work at finding common ground again
angela made sure that i got married and
that then i had some children so that we
could still be friends basically but
this is an important point because i
think it partly explains why we were
talking about how
30s is like you know the the decade
where your friendships die right where
they go where they go away uh because it
does take a lot of time in order to make
close friends and we obviously have
stats for this because we have stats for
everything so uh apparently a casual
friend
can take about 50 hours to develop so it
takes 50 hours
to develop a casual friendship
a very close friendship
takes an average of 200
hours now you may think to yourself well
200 hours
that's not that long except that the
average american spends approximately 40
minutes a day socializing so
think about like what that means like
the time and effort that it takes to
actually make a close friend
not when you're in your teens when
you've got nothing else going on except
your socialism or even in your 20s
really when you're still trying to
figure [ __ ] out but in your 30s when
it's like it's time to have a career and
maybe start a family the idea that i
would reserve 200 hours
to just
develop a new close friendship from the
ground up is
it's absurd there's no way i'm going to
ever do that you've only put about 17
hours into our friendship
and i got to be honest that's kind of my
cap that's my ceiling that's like 17
hours
but i do wonder if there's a gender
issue here as well you know do do women
naturally do you think make
deeper friendships better than men
because i will say that
um as uh
as a man i i've had a hard time i've
been in la for 20 years 21 years and
it's been hard for me here in 21 years
i'm in my mid-50s to make friendships
here most of my better friends are from
new york from before when i came to los
angeles and i i know there's been a
couple of times when i've reached out to
dudes i'm like oh maybe this person can
be kind of a better friend than someone
i have lunch with every six months or
play tennis with you know once or twice
a year and i've reached out and like
said hey what are you doing or
you know called on the phone or said hey
do you want to go hang out or like that
and it's
sometimes it's reciprocated but
sometimes it's really not and i don't
think it's like oh
they don't like me i'm not it's not a
boohoo thing
but it's kind of uh
i just it's not it's it's not uh natural
for men to say
oh i'm having a connection with another
adult male here let me foster this
encourage it nurture it and leave
voicemails you know and voice memos
every single day checking in on my
feelings and on funny stories that
happened to me when i stepped into dog
poo or accidentally blew my nose when i
didn't mean to or whatever you guys
leave on your messages
uh but i but i wonder if there's if
there's a difference because i i do know
that you know in some of the statistics
we were looking over that uh for so many
men they just they don't have
friends they might have a office high
five buddy or a drinking buddy or a
but but like a close friend and the wife
becomes the one close friend
of
of the uh of the fella yeah my wife is
constantly telling me like shouldn't you
call one of your friends and go hang out
with them and i was like no i want to
hang out with you
that is my husband i'll be like babe why
you should do one of those golfing trips
right like our did what do a
guy trip and he's like i don't know i
just kind of like to hang out with you
if i get any free time
then i'm like okay
um it is interesting and i know he has
really good friends from growing up in
college but
i am definitely his confidant in who he
turns to to to share with
you know i would have a question for
rayne and reza which is just
do you feel
like there's something missing for you i
mean
not having this intimate
friendship best friend person
outside of your marriage do you feel
like you're longing for something
i i if you had asked me that question
like
theoretically and in a vacuum i would
say absolutely absolutely there's
something missing for me um i shared
this at the opening that we i have a
best friend who lives in another state
we've been friends since we were you
know 16 years old uh
but
my wife jessica is my best friend and
and his 17 kids and my 17 kids uh and
she pretty much
fulfills
all of my
emotional
needs i and that might be weird
to say
but it's true like i'd rather hang out
with my wife than pretty much anyone
else
um so
whether that's healthy or not i i'm
totally willing to admit that it may not
be healthy that i probably should have
other people that i hang out with not in
a work environment like this uh but i
just don't i really don't it's basically
my wife is my best friend and for me i'm
really lucky because i have uh i have a
12-step recovery community and i have uh
my
faith community is baha'i
and there's people from both those
communities that i'm not necessarily
like buddy buddy like movies high-five
roller coasters kind of
friends but
but i can call anytime talk about deep
thoughts concepts you know issues ups
and downs and so that kind of fulfills
that for me but if i didn't have that in
my life like i think i really would feel
like there's something missing and i i i
bet you a lot of guys are a lot more
lonely than they let on to oh yeah
okay thanks so much you guys it's a
great book
to think about
well look but okay
so but bringing it to the book this is
what what i think is really fascinating
about this conversation because again as
adults we've already talked about how
hard it is to make friends and how long
it takes how much effort goes into it in
any case we have families and we have
wives and we have husbands and they
serve so many of those roles and so
basically the only other avenue
that most of us adults have
to make the kind of you know meaningful
lasting close intimate friendships is
work and so that's exactly what happened
to you guys right is that you were at
work
and you had to spend all these hours
together and that gave you the
opportunity to log those 200 hours that
it takes
to to become
close so i guess that's that's sort of
the next question that i have for you is
that are there certain environments for
instance like work
that can facilitate friendships um that
without those environments
it just i mean like where would i make
new friends i don't know i mean how
honestly like where am i gonna go that
i'm gonna make
a new friend and let alone a new best
friend
well i know for me once my kids started
school those school communities
i i have made some really good close
friends
in the other parents and um
that especially after going through a
pandemic together
we have a particularly tight bond
because we had this common interest of
our children's education and their
mental health and all of that and so
i mean i was
i was definitely having some more
intimate conversations more quickly with
some of these parents than maybe we
would have otherwise
but i think that there are other
circumstances that
kind of throw you into
i don't know making those kinds of
connections with people and i have to
say they have lasted
like um
and like i i really appreciate that so
maybe that and then i think you know
what rain was talking about your faith
environment
um
maybe if you have a recovery environment
but it does kind of like
i guess what i'm hearing is maybe it
takes an environment yeah like you need
a work or a church or something right
it's a little bit of a friendship what's
nature and nurture because i think jenna
and i
really are similar in the fact that we
like to to share with one another our
day
and it's something we enjoy doing i love
to hear about her day it makes me happy
the minutia the my name is all of it i
love to hear about it she organized her
closet today you guys
she can't stop tightening do you go by
color yeah that's a new thing to
organize closets by color by color but i
do think there's a chemistry element to
it just like any other relationship i
don't know that i want to hear anyone
else tell me about cleaning their closet
but i enjoy jenna telling me about her
closet i'll tell you about my day and
the minutiae of my i actually can't wait
i want to hear how derek is doing it
started with a poop oh well you don't
the consistency was you don't have to
tell me what it's like but are you is
your how's your constitution do you go
every day
yeah i'm i'm good i'm healthy we're good
we got a lot of we have a lot of uh ad
sponsors about that help us with our
poop for some reason i love listening to
podcast ads now that we do podcast ads i
find it fascinating i love to hear
everybody do their ads
um but the other thing i was going to
say is that i feel like
finding friends is also it's i almost as
we were talking about i was like is
there a friendship dating app like a
friendship app because friendster
was it was it really one no oh
friendster yeah friends you don't
remember friends it was right before
myspace oh yeah but yeah i mean i have
played tennis with the same group of
gals for like
10 years now and we see each other every
week and it's a totally different world
than jenna and i's world and i i love it
too i don't call them every day but we
see each other once a week and i know
how their families are doing and we play
tennis then we say goodbye so i feel
like there's all these different ways
where people can come into your life if
you're open to it
well um making friends as an adult john
cacciopo
social neuroscientist at the university
of chicago
found that while loneliness and
isolation build on themselves so do
friendships and community so in other
words
as you meet people
as you connect with people whether you
know jenna like at school or at the
tennis court or
you know in recovery or in your church
or a religious group as you meet and
connect with more and more people your
social skills grow they introduce you to
other people you expand your social
skills and confidence and uh so it it
feeds on itself so i would say maybe
one piece of advice for the listener out
there is like you've just got to start
right so you just kind of
start i don't know asking someone out
for a coffee or something like that
because it will snowball i know this
sounds so rudimentary but i think it's
important and i was going to ask you
guys do you have any other tips or
advice for people
wanting to start uh friendships yes top
five friendship tips
from jenna and angela from the office oh
my god listen i'm only an expert in my
friendship with angela i am not a
certified friendship expert i just want
to say all of these are just these are
just my spitball ideas that i'm throwing
at you we do love a list a moment's
notice we do love a list um i would say
if there's anything you're passionate
about volunteering an organization
get involved in something you're
passionate about because you'll meet
like-minded people
smart very smart there's one for me
jenna you go jenna you go
friendship expert jenna fisher
okay well i have a lot of social anxiety
actually and something that always
brings me comfort
is when someone told me that no one's
ever thinking about what you're doing
they're just thinking about the their
own thoughts in their heads so go ahead
and jump in because you don't have
anything to be afraid of and i think
like i think of that a lot because i
think well if i just be the first person
who starts talking that's okay i don't
have to be scared of that
i'll just say something friendly right
off the bat and then maybe that'll start
a conversation like even though by the
way that's like my advice is like a fake
it till you make it piece of advice
because i i guess i'm saying like i'm
not naturally outgoing or like naturally
confident in a social friendship
situation but i'll just be like well it
could be me i'll i'll i'll do it i'll
just do it it's like kind of like when
you're sad and you just kind of make
yourself kind of smile and you actually
that can turn your mood from a dark mood
to a happy mood
there's something about the using those
muscles the muscle memory yeah okay back
to me um
get outside get some vitamin d get
outside
walk around
you'll probably walk into someone and
say hi that's the worst advice i've ever
ever you have that is
that
says hi to a stranger on the street wait
can i say something off of angela's
piece of advice a few weeks ago
i went on a walk around my neighborhood
and i had put on my prescription
sunglasses and taken my prescription
eyeglasses off and tucked them into the
collar of my sweatshirt
when i got home from my walk i went to
put my regular eyeglasses back on and
they had fallen somewhere in my walk
dear god just fallen off right this is
probably what one of your messages to
actually sound i already know the story
i already know the story okay continue
so i had to go out and retrace my steps
and along the way i stopped anybody that
i saw and i asked them if they had seen
a pair of eyeglasses
and i explained what happened
the conversations i had that day with my
neighbors and people walking down the
street were an utter delight such a
delight that i thought i should go home
and write a short film about this
because
this me being a person who lost her
eyeglasses has turned into like seven
beautiful moments of connection with
other human beings thank you jenna thank
you you're welcome angela this is the
same experience i had when i met george
because he was cleaning his rv that he
parked next to his house and i found out
all about him and his wife bobby she
danced she was a professional dancer
like a studio like remember when you
were a studio gal
fascinating
love them
and every once while they have lunch in
their rv and i walk by and say hi
that's great rainbow uh-huh watching the
rv you have to pivot now rain you have
to pivot no it's up to you reza can you
salvage this conversation
are you kidding i'm i'm taking notes
here like uh say say hi to people this
is
get outside
go outside start conversations
this is good stuff uh-huh write your
short film okay
yes make a short film
lesson about friendship oh let's hear it
i recently joined a little tennis club
in my new town where i moved outside of
los angeles do you ever need a sassy
blonde i need a sassy four foot six
tennis ball five one and a half um
but i
there uh i was a little nervous because
i was i'm not i'm mediocre at tennis and
i was just starting out and these guys
had been playing for 10 years and stuff
like that and there was this guy
named walter which is also my son's name
and
he was just very like he was relatively
new himself he was just very positive
and he just was like come on to a new
game like hey guys i'm walter and
someone had a nice survey today hey
great serve and he'd learn their name
and say great serve and you were like oh
it's a beautiful night for tennis it was
just like lobbing these like positivity
grenades out and i was like you know
i really appreciate i want to be like
walter more because you know i can be
such a such a grump you
come on and um i do want to tell that
story about on the set of the office of
my my favorite stories um but i i
learned something from walter at tennis
about like just someone who who come and
and i thought this about my father too
as i my father passed away about a year
and a half two years ago and
as i was in kind of doing some memorials
for him and thinking about his life and
did a little writing about him i
realized like my dad always made a room
a better place when he went into it he
just always added something positive a
compliment a joke something uplifting he
never kind of came in and just went
and sucked the energy out he was just
lobbing kind of positive grenades like
the like walter the tennis player this
is a little different from me
when
every morning i would come in the office
at about six
you know 27 a.m onto the set i've
already been up and had my hair and
makeup done and everyone on the cruise
like hi rain good morning rain hey rain
how's it going rain good morning hey
rain hi
it was it was like a 1950s musical top
of the morning to you good morning say
hello hi how are you doing it really was
like that and it's like and there's like
87 crew members and finally at one point
i said everyone was like just an
announcement
let's all say hi on monday mornings and
say hi to everyone and ask about our
weekends and then the rest of the week
like we don't have to can we take a
break on the good morning it's so
oppressive
it's so impressive let me tell you the
room turned on him they really people
are like well excuse me for saying good
morning to you i would have called tmz
that afternoon that afternoon i'd be on
the phone with tmz but it was like guys
come on i just saw you 24 i saw you not
even that i say 12 hours ago and said hi
or good goodbye don't it's oppressive
it's a tyranny of hellos
that's your next book by the way tyranny
of hellos that's your next book
rain i loved you so much in that moment
here is my other tip for friendship
which is that you have to be your honest
self oh because i'm not i know
i know and love you
as your honest self because you've shown
me who you are and
and i love you for it and also by the
way rain i felt weighted down by those
good mornings as well so i felt like
you kind of were speaking for a few of
us who were afraid to speak up and say
stop saying hello
morning true jenna loves going to new
york city and i've been there with her
now and it's because people don't really
talk to each other like when you walk
down the street you know you just you're
doing your business but if you do talk
to each other you give it to each other
straight like i remember being in new
york and i remember
standing in line at a coffee place
and this woman got her coffee and she
took a sip and she said this isn't right
i need you to do it again
and i was like oh my gosh that was so
just straightforward it wasn't rude it
wasn't me and it was just matter of fact
and i my heart was singing because i
grew up in the midwest if you take a sip
of your coffee and it's wrong you live
with it
or you say i am so sorry i'm sure i
misspoke i'm sure it's my fault this is
it's not quite what i meant did you is
it the sugar free because this tastes
like the regular i don't you know what
forget it forget it and then you walk
out
so to have someone be like this is
incorrect i need you to make it again
i i was like
i couldn't believe it and so rain for me
in that moment
you were that woman in the coffee shop
and i was like i love this man i love
him
he is just he is speaking his truth and
i love a person angela has mocked me for
that moment for 10 years
listen my favorite thing about that
moment was
was the five seconds after he stopped
talking where everyone just like glared
at you it was like
so cringy it was amazing i love cringe
comedy that was like so fantastic
i mean i'm a very positive person i love
people i love talking to people but you
know i have a dark sense of humor so to
watch you kind of flail there for a
minute
was delicious
well look this is uh i mean it's so fun
to talk to you guys and talk about you
know friendships and how to make
friendships and all that stuff but this
is kind of a serious topic as well i
mean you guys know that we have
what a lot of people are calling a
loneliness epidemic in this country uh
there was a survey from cigna in 2019
that said 61 of americans report
being lonely that was before the
pandemic and we've already talked about
the fact that like making friends
requires hours and hours of contact that
usually that contact happens
face to face or in social situations at
work or whatever and then we spent two
years locked in our homes
so
the vast majorities of americans
reported
um
huge spikes in their loneliness in their
depression
i think 13 percent about a year into the
pandemic 13 of women and 8 percent of
men
between the ages of 30 and 49 said that
they had lost touch with most of their
friends
right so
you know we're at this place now where
we're slowly coming out of the pandemic
we're slowly seeing each other again
it's like we're coming out of the dark
and like squinting into the light we
barely know how to form sentences with
each other we've lost all
social uh norms and and social behavior
uh
uh capabilities
so what can you sort of say about how
important friendship is to having an
actual like healthy mental and emotional
life um and then any words of
encouragement for
those of us who have spent two years in
our pajamas
uh and who have like lost the ability to
even like talk to people anymore
well i mean angela totally
is so good for my mental health i mean i
just don't know what i would do without
her truly
i had a really hard time the pandemic
because i'm a social person i love going
to things i love seeing people i love
gatherings
and i struggled i you know would have a
friend over in the driveway and we'd
stand far apart or have a
one friend over to the yard we did that
a few times and i'd be so happy to see
them but then as soon as they left so
sad that it was
so
odd and we couldn't just
sit down next to each other and i
couldn't give him a hug and
so i really feel for people out there
that are kind of that missed that
that time in their life and those
connections in your life and i would
look so forward to seeing jenna we used
to do this edit zoom we would edit over
zoom
and i would see jenna and our sound
engineer sam and our producer cassie
from the podcast and i would be so
excited you guys have a podcast
office ladies obviously
yes um but it was a hard time for me and
and jenna knew that and she would
reach out to me during that time and i
think it's
it's something we started the talking
about at the beginning of this podcast
which was
reaching out to people even people who
you think don't want you to reach out
and rain every once in a while you text
me out of the blue jen and i have talked
about this you'll text us out of the
blue with something you know something
like
hey idiot i love you or something like
that
and i'm always like oh rain and it makes
me so happy and i try to encourage
myself to reach out to people even
people who i think oh they've got their
their [ __ ] together and
you know what everyone loves a moment of
connection they do
you know there's uh
a loneliness epidemic going on
we had dr varun sony on an episode he's
the chaplain and a professor at usc
fantastic uh
spiritual
teacher and thinker um
and he described firsthand his
experience
with the college kids at usc and you
know the
suicide ideation and uh
the you know how fractured everyone
was and you know so we've kind of read
through some of these statistics on
loneliness and it's really crept up
especially in the last 10 years and now
we've got covent on top of it and we're
talking about friendship and loneliness
feeds into friendship obviously the
the opposite of loneliness is connection
and connection is
friendship and uh but part of it i uh
always comes back to this idea of social
media so you know for a lot of young
people you have a phone in your hand and
you've got an instagram account and it's
like look i have 244 friends and look i
post a picture of me and my parrot and
87 people liked it and waved at it and
thumbs up it and commented on we're
friends but you're not friends that's
not a sign of friendship it's a
completely superficial interaction and i
think it can
fool people um and i'm just wondering
you guys are social media queens you're
so good at it but you have such rich
family lives and social lives beyond
that but in your interactions with with
young folk when when you guys do
speaking gigs and pods and and whatnot
how do you feel like the social media
world has influenced the world of
friendship
well listen at the beginning of the
podcast angela and i said that the way
we became best friends was by talking
face-to-face with each other on that
bench
and i think that
that there are
great things about social media and the
internet and things like
being able to order something and it
just comes to your house but the cost
we're paying for all of those things is
the
the lessening of that face-to-face
contact or that um
the speaking to one another i mean how
often do i text people instead of
calling them on the phone now i mean
texting has even i think
it kind of drives a wedge there and um
and i think that's part of with angela
and i with the audio memos
it's the hearing the long-form
voice
uh listening to one another's voices is
a big part of how we connect
and
i think we can feel like there's not
time for that oh well i only have time
to text i don't have time to actually
get on a phone call with you but i think
that like all of that all of that limits
connection
well and i feel like social media is a
shortcut to connection
it's not putting in the
200 hours right it's a shortcut and
everybody wants to feel seen and heard
and you have to take time to do that you
have to put in the time to do that so
i i mean one of the things my kids are
getting older now and um they're not on
instagram
but one of the things i talk to them
about it because they see me using
instagram
is that it's it's just
it's a way to sort of see a little bit
of people's lives but they're only
showing you what they want you to see
you're not seeing a full picture
and there are wonderful things about
seeing how people live or connecting
with people from a different country or
different place
but you're just getting a small glimpse
and you have to go into it knowing that
you know i'm really glad that you guys
uh
are talking about this and and you know
the book is wonderful
because
you know this isn't just about mental
health actually um
there have been numerous studies it was
a meta-analysis uh at byu
that concluded that
loneliness
can be as harmful to your physical
health as smoking 15 cigarettes a day
and now the previous surgeon general you
know called loneliness a public health
epidemic not just a mental
uh health epidemic um the united kingdom
now has a minister for loneliness
like there's actually a government
minister whose job is to deal with the
loneliness of uh the english people
which that's a big job actually um
other governments are spending tens of
millions of dollars trying to treat this
i mean it's it's like it's becoming
almost like any other kind of public
health problem and so
i i really love the way that you guys
are talking about
the importance of building these kinds
of connections even if it's little you
know in little bite-sized moments a
phone call here
a voice message a text any attempt to
create connections and and i and i also
love angela's advice that
you may think that somebody out there is
fine that they've got plenty of friends
that they're doing fine but just check
in check in with them and find out and
and you might be surprised and it might
actually create an interesting
connection
um for you that's all i think super
super important for people to hear these
days
yeah i really try now more um
[Music]
my i
had a loss in my family that was from
loneliness
um
and depression and um
it's just changed completely
how i think about reaching out to people
and
i don't even need a response back that's
the thing it's just me reaching out so i
can see
something you did on tv rain or catch a
little glimpse of one of our friends and
their career and maybe it makes me think
of them and i shoot them a little thing
like
i recently texted kate flannery because
she's so hilarious in the st patrick's
day episode of the office and i was like
kate when you say not today
you know like they can't fight on st
patrick's day it's the one day right
kelly and ryan
and i just texted her and i was like i
don't need kate to text me back and i
knew she was traveling but i knew
whenever she got to her destination she
would see that text
and i've just tried to be better and
some days you're better at connecting
with people than others but um
you just never know where people are at
and you never know
what that
reach to them might mean
i think the um
it just makes me think about being a
human being and you know connection in
community
collaboration connectivity
consultation all of those c words are
just so integral to what it is to be a
human we're we're we're tribal creatures
we're we're we're pack animals you know
no that's not the right it that's not
the right phrase what is it
what are animals like social animals
that social animals that have to be like
together together heard a hurt her dad
yeah um
but you know this
it's so essentially human to have these
moments of connection that you guys have
been describing and jenna i was so moved
hearing you saying that how how angela
has been there has helped your mental
health so much like there's so much to
be gained from a deep friendship when
you're going through a hard time someone
is there for you you know they've got
your back they're reaching out just out
of the blue like you said angela just um
and and i do think guys this is one of
the incredible
bounties of the office that i had no
idea when we were filming it that this
would be the legacy of the office yes if
the office is really funny and it has a
really talented cast and writers and
directors but
the the reason people go back to it over
and over and over again um
is because of those human moments and
those human connections and even the
lack of connection and the fumbling to
try and connect and the and the
the misguided attempts at connection
that happen over and over again
throughout the show and the awkward
pauses which are just a very real part
of life but
that essential humanness of the show i
think over and above the comedy is what
has made it a classic
and
so i kind of feel like this book is an
extension of that like you're you're
continuing this kind of like legacy of
the of the heart of the office that i
don't even think greg daniels i mean he
had an inkling but i don't think he's
set out to
i'm going to create this great humanist
work of art you know he's just like i
want to make a smart comedy that's kind
of dark and weird and slow and looks
different and you know helps the state
of american comedy which was in pretty
bad uh graces at that time um
but uh it's an incredible legacy that
you guys are you're carrying the torch
for we really wanted
the takeaway to be about not just angela
and i's friendship but the friendship
and connection that we all felt while
making the show and that we now feel
with the people who watch the show when
we meet them and just
there is a
there is a little community there and it
means a lot to me and we get
so much feedback and rain i'm sure you
do as well but especially since we
started the podcast so many people reach
out to us and say
i met my husband because he told me to
watch the office and i had never seen it
and we worked together so we started
watching the office together and then we
got married and now our kids are
watching it with us so it and there's
there's trivia nights there's like
office trivia night where you can go did
you see the photos from the office
5k marathon in scranton no people
dressed as office characters and did a
5k
yeah oh that's amazing but it is and
there's a convention this summer too
there's a convention but it there's a
musical in new york the office musical
so there is a real community
of people that love the show and they're
making connections with one another and
friendships and marriages and and that
makes me so happy that the show is
bringing people together still after all
these years and what would people get
tattooed if they didn't have the office
i know
a number of times did you stay did you
see the you and i on that was great that
was great on a thought yeah we're on a
thigh
well the book is called the office bffs
by jenna fisher and angela kinsey it's
so much fun to read if you're an office
fan it's great because it's got all
these behind the scenes photos of all
you guys the whole cast and creatures
angela chapter yes i read angela chapter
so the whole book is a conversation
between jen and i and we go back and
forth and back and forth except for two
chapters jenna wrote a chapter called
jam and i wrote a chapter called
dwangela did you learn anything while
reading the book rain like is there
anything that you were like oh my gosh i
didn't know that it is so cute that you
think that rain reads books
oh i learned a ton
but i can't believe you guys remembered
all this [ __ ] like there's stuff you're
talking about like we did like you were
describing our first scene
making out in that tree house and you
detailed like i don't remember a thing
i remember that we were in a tree house
and it was the haida key rock joke it
was at jim's house and we were in a tree
house and we had to position our brick
and stocks and that was awkward
and other than that i mean you were
talking about i lent you my scarf and
then we switched to positions
and what we talked about and what we ate
at the snack break and it was a magical
moment for angela it was so i have
journals i so jen and i both were
journal writers and we kept journals and
then the other thing we used to do to
stay in touch before you know we didn't
have smartphones is jen and i would
email each other about our day or what
happened and things and we had all of
this digital clutter plus our journals
but that i remember rain because i was
so nervous because it was my first big
storyline and it was the beginning of it
and i was freezing cold and i didn't
know how to talk to you and i was a
little intimidated
and then i told you that i grew up in
indonesia and you didn't believe me at
first
and then we started having this whole
conversation yeah yeah i love it when
you speak indonesian it's so sexy say
something now
rain right now i'm talking to my friend
rayne yeah that is very sexy actually
you're right it's fantastic
jenna angela it's so great to see you
both it's great to be in the same room
as you look at you
and uh
angela angela let's go
i'm gonna have 200 people say good
morning to you this week oh dear lord
thanks guys
thank you guys thanks so much for having
us thank you reza
ladies and gentlemen uh a new little
section of the podcast we're trying it's
called
i drink your milkshake
it's where reza and i
are on opposite sides
of an idea and today that idea is can
you only have
one
best
friend i mean is the word best superb
it's such a superlative it's best that
there's no one
can you have equal best friends or only
one what no what is that
wait what
no you can't have more than one best
friend that's absurd no you why don't
they have to earn best friend why is
that absurd the definition of best
friend is your best
friend but you can have another equally
best friend maybe not a better friend
but an equally best friend why couldn't
you have seven
amazing intimate
friendships same-sex friendships or
different sex gender friendships and
all equal and all intimate and fun and
connected and you love to hang out and
you share vulnerable things with seven
different people why not listen there's
only one most valuable player okay
there's only one first place
all right you can't be first place
runner-up
all right
there can only be one best friend it's
called a participation trophy why don't
you get participation trophies to your
seven best friends fine you can have
participation friends but you can only
really have one
best friend the real question
this is a this is a more important
question okay
do you really need more than
say
three friends
i mean i i i'm with that like 49 of
americans i know that we talked about it
as some like
sad thing that oh 49 of americans only
have three friends yeah that's a lot of
friends
well i i look at friends as like a layer
cake it's a tier system
you've got your
three or four or five like best friend
buddies at the top of the wedding cake
the next tier down you've got
seven folks you can call at any time
share you love to catch up with you want
to hear about their families then the
next tear down like people you want to
hang out with play golf shoot the [ __ ]
with have lunch with
and then
you know what i mean and so on and so on
i guess
acquaintances acquaintances maybe sure
sure yeah but when we lived in tribes
how did friendships work okay let's go
back to
150 people in a series of caves
uh in a tribe
would you you know would plague only
hang out with flaku you know or listen
it was only whoever whoever shared my
meat okay that's that's who was my
friend
and as it is now i've got enough meat to
go around for three people
like that is
that's about as much meat as i can spare
three people worth of meat
well now thanks to grubhub we can have
meat at your door in 27 minutes
for all of your friends all right maybe
you and i are never gonna uh agree on
this on this uh point although i'm not
exactly sure which one of us drank the
other's milkshake but listeners
listeners surely you have some ideas
about this can you have more than one
best friend
how many friends
is enough
friends we would love to hear from you
you can find us on social media at reza
aslan and rayne wilson and on twitter at
metamilkpodcast
on instagram at metaphysical milkshake
let us know
how many friends is enough friends and
guess what we've been doing this a lot
lately and i i kind of like this part
we're going to be giving away some
copies of jenna and angela's new book
the office bffs
it's easy you want a copy of a free book
a free heavy heavy book full of
fun stories and pictures is it a coffee
table book it's basically a coffee table
book yeah it's the size of a coffee
table it weighs about as much as a
coffee table does uh but the first five
people very easy the first five people
who write
a review for metaphysical milkshake on
apple podcast and hopefully it's a
positive review i mean i guess we can't
really force you to do that but the
first five people to write a review uh
for medifical metaphysical milkshake on
apple podcast all you got to do is take
a screenshot of it and email it to us at
metaphysical
cast media that's k-a-s-t media dot com
you'll get a copy of the book so do you
want any more of life's big questions
find us on social media at reza aslan
rayne wilson on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram
especially at metaphysical milkshake
and let us know your life's big
questions and we might just explore them
on a future episode please follow rate
review metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts wherever else you listen to
podcasts and please please if you like
looking at me right here right now
waving my hands looking like an idiot
follow us on our youtube channel on the
metaphysical milkshake uh youtube and
you can watch our episodes every week
you'll actually get to see angela and uh
and jenna that's right yeah in the flesh
in the flesh thanks for listening milk
shakers see you next week see you next
week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
well jenna says i i just talked and
talked and talked and talked and talked
until she was like okay okay i'll be
here we're friends
is that the key to friendship can we end
the podcast right now and we're done
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you